Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. So this is
gonna be a breakdown
of the Missy clip that the BBC just posted.
They just confirmed that she's coming back for Series 9.
They've been filming since January and I
believe Moffat said he had almost three
scripts ready before they even got
started so
you should expect them to start making
more casting announcements in the next
few months as production continues.
They've already announced a whole bunch of guest
cast so I'll explain who they are at the end of the video.
This is mostly gonna be about the Missy the
footage and the first two episodes. Oh, and
just because this is my first Doctor Who video
of the year I'm just doing
a spontaneous giveaway. All you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video.
It's just a twenty dollar Amazon gift card.
So I'll announce the details for that at the end of this.
Juicy apple.
I can't remember who
who ate the apple. Was it Adam
or was it Eve? I don't know.
I've no idea.
Oh, it was the serpent who was a bit evil.
Anyway, I like apples.
I'm back.
So this is a really odd video that the BBC posted.
Moffat already said that Missy was
coming back, now it's confirmed. Usually
the first videos that we get from Doctor Who
aren't official. Usually it's, like, someone
camping out on the set when they film outdoors.
It's possible that they're getting ready
to film some outdoor Missy scenes or
something like that and that's why they
posted this,
so that someone wouldn't leak it first.
But most important stuff, so
Episode 1, we already knew it's called 'The
Magician's Apprentice'. Episode 2
is called 'The Witch's Familiar'. It's a
two part premiere that Missy's gonna be a big part of.
We don't know if she's gonna be the main
villain in Series 9 like she was in Series 8
or if she'll just be a background
player. I like the juxtaposition with the titles.
It might offer some clues as to what
the new dynamic is gonna be between
the Doctor, Clara, and Missy. I'm expecting
it to be
pretty contained to those three people, I'm
not expecting, like, some new character to come along.
That would be crazy if Missy got her own
apprentice, so to speak.
I don't think that's gonna happen, I
think Moffat likes to keep things a little
more self-contained.
There's no official premiere date on
that first episode but
they did say autumn 2015, so until they
get more specific
just expect Series 9 to premiere
about the same time Series 8 premiered.
So in the promo Missy's eating the apple,
commenting on the story
of the Biblical Garden of Eden.
Adam and Eve, the beginning of evil, the birth of knowledge, you know, depending on your interpretation.
The apple represents knowledge as well as
evil. So let's pick that apart.
Just looking at it from Missy's
perspective first, the garden could represent
that garden in the data slice, the one
that she always walked around in in Series 8.
In the Biblical sense it's also a point
of origin, it represents paradise,
the origin of man, so it could also
represent Gallifrey,
at least for Missy. I mean, that's her idea
of paradise.
Depending on whose perspective you take
the Doctor, Clara, or Missy, the metaphors
change quite a bit.
Like paradise for the Doctor is travelling in
the TARDIS with his companion
but paradise for Clara might be life with
Danny Pink. Since this is Missy's video
we'll start with her.
So you could say the Doctor's Adam, Missy is
Eve and Clara's the snake
who wants to destroy Missy's paradise by
giving the apple to the Doctor.
Or when you take the Doctor's
perspective you could say that Missy is
the snake giving Clara the apple
destroying his paradise, destroying his
life in the TARDIS with his companion.
Missy's obsessed with the Doctor. She wants
him all to herself so she's probably
gonna try and break their relationship
somehow.
Missy's only been confirmed for the first
two episodes so she might just pop up
across Series 9. I don't think they'd make
such a big deal about her if she wasn't
gonna come back before the finale.
But we have no idea how she's gonna figure
into the overarching plot of Series 9
like the major story.
So tying this back to the end of Series 8,
the garden could represent Gallifrey.
Just because we're still looking for
Gallifrey doesn't mean that we'll actually
find it in Series 9 but I do think
that they'll be dancing around it.
You guys can let me know whether you agree
or not but do you feel like Gallifrey
works better as a red herring,
like as an idea in the Doctor's head, in
the Doctor and Missy's head,
or do you think it would be better if they,
like, literally brought it back
into the Doctor Who Universe proper, like
if the Doctor could set foot
on Gallifrey soil. that would mean the Time
Lords coming back and them having to
incorporate them into the story somehow.
It almost feels like it would cause more
problems than it would solve. Like I feel
like the only time they would bring the
Time Lords back
proper would be if they were going to be
the major villain or major protagonists
of the season and the Doctor's always gonna
be the main protagonist of the season.
If you look at in the context of Series
8, I mean they did kind of visit Gallifrey,
there was a lot of arguing after that episode
where Clark talked to the Doctor as a boy about
where that shed actually was. It
sounded like, based on the way the press
talked about it, they actually were on Gallifrey
but I don't ever remember Moffat
confirming it. That's always the funny thing
with Moffat explanations, like sometimes
when people ask him questions at conventions
he'll answer a question with a question.
Speaking of which, next big question. How did
Missy survive the Series 8 finale?
I'm sure Moffat's explanation in the
first couple episodes will involve some comedy
but the short answer is her compact sonic
teleported her away instead of
vaporizing her. That's why they had the blue
beam instead of the red one.
It wasn't confirmed whether or not she
had a TARDIS in Series 8. It seemed like she did.
What I'd really like to see is the
inside of that TARDIS.
The only other explanation for her
jumping around in time would be a vortex manipulator.
So that's possible too but I think a Master TARDIS
would be so much more fun. Here's my big
question for you guys. What are somethings
that you'd like to see them do with the
Master character, or the Mistress character,
however you want to think about her,
now that we know she's coming back? While you guys
think about that, here's actually some
of the confirmed guest cast that they've
already announced.
So first up is Paul Kaye, he's like the first
big guest actor.
He's gonna be playing someone named
Prentis in the first two episodes.
You probably know him as Thoros of Myr from
Game of Thrones. He had this really awesome quote.
"As a kid of the 1970s, the two shows you always watched were Top Of The Pops
and Doctor Who, they were unmissable. I
actually wrote a song called
‘Looking For Davros’ in my first punk
band and I sang it like a demented Dalek.
I got to present TOTP back in the mid '90s
and landing this role in Doctor Who
completes the dream double”.
And then he goes on to say “Peter is a
perfect Doctor and I’m loving every
minute of the experience,"
I guess he's already filmed some of his scenes.
"even the five hours in makeup.
What a treat, best 50th birthday
present ever!” That five hours in makeup
just makes it sound like he's playing an
alien character or he's going to have a lot of prosthetics.
The rest of the people they've announced
include Morven Christie who was in 'Grantchester',
Arsher Ali from 'The Missing', Colin
McFarlane from 'EastEnders',
and Sophie Stone from 'Midsomer Murders'.
Just the way that they talk about those
people in the press release makes
it sound like they'll appear at least in the
first block of episodes
if not the first two. So what I'm probably gonna do
because there's no Doctor Who going on
right now and we're ramping up for Game
of Thrones so I'm mostly focusing on that stuff
is I'll wait for, like, really big Doctor
Who announcements to do bonus videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Just to explain the giveaway, I'm gonna
announce the winner whenever I post my
next Game of Thrones video since I'm
probably not going to post another Doctor
Who video for a little while.
The BBC hasn't really announced
whether or not they're going to do
another world tour or how they're going
to promote Series 9
but that's probably not gonna start till
August regardless. So just expect to hear
regular casting announcements for the
next couple of months. We'll probably learn
what some of the other episode titles are.
Right now there's only four episodes
listed on IMDB, we only know the names of the first two.
So while you guys wait for more Doctor Who news
just in case you missed any of it, you
can click here for all my Doctor Who
Series 8 videos
and you can click here to catch up on
Game of Thrones, I just posted a Jon Snow
video a little while ago.
So thank you so much for watching, I'll see
you guys tonight. High-fives.